كرر رئيس الحكومه الباكستانيه شهباز شريف
تاني دهو بمحاوله اغتيال سلفه عمران خان
واضاف في مؤتمر صحفي في لاهور انه امر
باجراء تحقيق شامل منتقدا موقفه خان الذي
اتهمه بتورط في التخطيط الاختلاله ومتعهدا
بالاستقاله اذا ثبتت هذه الاتهامات هذا
وداع حزب انصاف بزعامه الرئيس الحكومه
المقال عمران خان لمحاكمه الجنرال فيصل
نصير التابعي لجهاز الاستخبارات لما وصفه
بدوره في التخطيط لاختيار خان يوم الخميس
الماضي في المدينه وزير باب اقليم البنجر
في تغريده لها دعا الجيش لعدم الخلق بين
اتهام الحزب للجنرال فيصل واحترامه للجيش
وقيادته بصفه عامه من جانبه عبر الجنرال
بابر افتخار الناطق باسم القوات المسلحه
الباكستانيه
برتبه جنرال استخباراته بالتخطيط
الاختيالي خان
كان الجيش والباكستاني قد رفضتها مات
عمران خان ووصفها بالباطله وهذا الجيش في
بيانه الحكومه لاجراء تحقيق موسع في
محاولات الاعتداء على خانه كما حذر بيان
الجيش من مغبه التعرض لاي من ضباطه كان
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان قد اتهم
رئيس الوزراء الحالي شباب الشريف بالتورط
في محاوله اغتياله واشار لانه من غير
الممكن تحقيق العداله ما لم تتم اقالته
رفقه وزير الداخليه واحد جنرالات جهاز
الاستخبارات العسكريه واكد خان ان على
الباكستانيين الانخراطه في ثوره انما
سلميه او دمويه على حديث
كثير
كيف يمكن تحقيق العداله ما لم يستقيل كل
من رئيس الحكومه ووزير الداخليه والجنرال
فيصل من جهاز المخابرات
بصفته قائد الجيش والذي يحترمه كثيرا
بالتحرك للحفاظ على سمعه الجيش فهؤلاء
يعتقدون اننا لسنا بشر وانما خرافا نتحرك
وفقه هواهم اقول الان امامنا طريقان اما
ان تحدث ثوره سميه في باكستان او ثوره
دمويه